hello I'm McGowan welcome to Cadogan
Hall in London for an intelligence
squared debate on one of the most
contentious issues in European politics
that the policies of German Chancellor
Angela Merkel are destroying Europe no
one blames Germany for the 2008 global
financial crisis but many argue that
Chancellor Merkel's insistence on severe
spending cuts and enforced deficit
reductions in countries like Greece
Portugal and Spain have really
threatened the stability both of the
European Union and the eurozone so the
motion for debate here Angela Merkel is
destroying Europe and we have an
excellent panel for you arguing for the
motion Mehdi Hassan political director
of The Huffington Post UK he's author of
a book on austerity myths the debt
delusion and euclid tsakalotos from
Greece a member of parliament for the
syriza party economic adviser to Alexis
tsipras who is the party leader against
the motion
Kristine Okrand a prominent voice in the
French media former head of France franc
caps and Radio France Internationale and
former editor-in-chief of the weekly
news magazine lex press and antony
Beaver Award winning historian of the
20th century ladies and gentlemen our
panel
well shortly your hear from the four
panelists - for the motion - against the
debate will then be thrown open to the
floor
the audience was polled before the
debate I'll give you details of that
after we've heard from each of our
speakers the audience will then vote
again to see how opinion has changed now
the opening statements from the
panelists let's hear first of all
speaking for the motion Mehdi Hassan as
well as being political director of The
Huffington Post in the UK he is
biographer of Labour leader Ed Miliband
and the author of an e-book on austerity
myths Mabius on the floor is yours
ladies and gentlemen tonight I'm here
we're here to persuade you all that
Chancellor Angela Merkel of Germany is
destroying Europe but let's be very
clear before we go any further as to
what this debate is not number one this
is not a debate about Angela Merkel per
se the proposition is not here tonight
to attack her as a person but only to
attack to critique to reject her
destructive policies and by extension I
should add the policies of pretty much
the entire German establishment number
two when we say Germany or Merkel is
quote destroying Europe we're referring
to the very visible very undeniable
damage being done to the economic and
social fabric of countries such as
Greece Spain Portugal Ireland and number
three this isn't a debate where we say
Germany has no right to pursue its
national interest of course not of
course it does but the question remains
is Germany's unflinching unrelenting
all-consuming pursuit of its own
national interest at all costs
destroying the rest of Europe
particularly southern Europe we believe
it is how so well primarily through
austerity misguided self-defeating
austerity Merkel and Germany's preferred
solution to Europe's growth debt and
jobs crises ie cuts cuts and more cuts
has brought the continent to the edge of
a second Great Depression and today
under Merkel Germany for so long the
driving force of Europe's growth
prosperity unity now finds itself
isolate
once again loathe and feared in equal
measure Merkel did not cause Europe's
financial crisis that dishonor still
belongs to the world's top bankers but
her deficit fetishism her Hoover esque
obsession with balanced budgets and
severe spending cuts helped produce the
eurozone's longest ever recession and
continues to threaten to disrupt six
decades of pan-european stability and
unity as we shall see tonight her
supporters argue that this is totally
unfair the iron chancellor they believe
is standing up for hard-working Germans
who are weary of having to bail out
their feckless and profligate southern
European neighbors but this argument
ladies and gentlemen is utter utter
nonsense fecklessness figures compiled
by the OECD show that on average the
lazy Greek worker Labor's for 2,000
hours a year which is more than 40
percent longer than the average German
does so a little less schadenfreude a
please and as for profligacy despite
what Frau Merkel and our friends would
have you believe it has little to do
with Europe's current crisis Spain's
downturn was caused not by excessive
government spending or public debt but
by the wholly unsustainable growth in
private debt particularly in the
financial real estate and insurance
sectors thanks to the crash Spain went
from having one of the lowest public
debt to GDP ratios in the entire
eurozone to one of the highest so let's
junk this overspending myth - in fact
it's under spending it's Merkel
prescribed austerity that is to blame
for the current growth crisis where I
should say lack of growth crisis
the results are in austerity isn't
working it has failed in September the
unemployment rate in the eurozone hit a
record high of 12 point 2 percent that's
20 million people the situation for
young people meanwhile is beyond our
it's heartbreaking youth unemployment
stands at 35 percent in Portugal a
mind-boggling 56 percent in Spain a
whopping 61 percent in Greece this is a
human tragedy plain and simple
it's the willful destruction yes
destruction of an entire European
generation but Merkel won't budge she's
the chief purveyor of the very
conventional wisdom that says an economy
is like a household it shouldn't spend
or burrow
beyond what it earns but economies are
not households or credit cards for that
matter and common sense if not basic
macroeconomic theory tells us that the
solution to a downturn caused by a
drought in demand is not to cut demand
further by everyone slashing spending at
once history teaches us that the Great
Depression wasn't helped by u.s.
President Herbert Hoover's austerity
measures and in pre-war Germany was mass
unemployment not hyperinflation that
propelled Hitler to power isn't it
ironic that the leader of a nation
understandably paranoid about and
offended by any mention of its Nazi past
seemed so relaxed about the rise in
recent years our anti-austerity neo-nazi
far-right parties across Europe from
marine lepen National Front to Greece's
black shirted Golden Dawn - the fascists
of yo Bukh now the third largest party
in Hungary Merkel however prefers to
fiddle not just as Athens burns but
Madrid and Lisbon and yes Rome - ladies
and gentlemen in denial indifferent to
human suffering bent on austerity at all
costs Angela Merkel is destroying the
European project pauper izing her
neighbours and risking a new continent
white if not global Great Depression she
must be stopped she must be sent a
message ladies and gentlemen I urge you
to vote YES tonight send that message
tonight I beg to propose thank you very
much
maybe and thank you very much indeed now
let's move to the first speaker against
the motion christine Okrent a
distinguished French journalist who
writes for the International New York
Times el pais The Guardian and other
European newspapers thank you Nick
I will try and convince you that all the
very good arguments of this very
eloquent young man are misled Angela
Merkel is not destroying Europe of
course Angela Merkel is not perfect
there's no perfect leader do you know of
any we might need one on the other side
of the channel the truth is that Angela
Merkel is the head of a strong
parliamentary democracy with checks and
balances which were imposed upon Germany
very strict ones by the British and the
American Victor's after World War two
she is no whimsical temper a mental
block thirty guys are marching upon
Europe
she has been reelected three times by
German citizens which tends to show that
they appreciate her leadership she does
not actually dictate the policies of
Europe not even the policies of the
eurozone for the very simple reason that
there is no common economic policy of
the eurozone which by the way is part of
its problem the truth of the matter is
that Angela Merkel has been skilled
enough to maintain and indeed amplify
the policies of her Social Democrat
predecessor Garrett shredder and the
2010 agenda at the time where Germany
was actually nicknamed the sick man of
Europe and indeed through very harsh
sacrifice and labor and all sorts of
agreements which the trade unions agreed
upon the self-discipline of the Germans
have indeed made it so that today
Germany is the
strongest kid in the block now that may
not be comfortable for all of us
especially on the continent but still it
is a fact Angela Merkel is not
responsible for the disastrous policies
which have been ruining southern Europe
galloping deficits collapse of
competitiveness real estate bubbles
banking system failed and the cheating
on economic figures to join the Euro
Spain Portugal Italy for other reasons
Greece who are the responsible people
not Merkel but those incompetent myopic
if not corrupt elites which have
government after government and
especially in Greece let the countries
into this kind of a B's of course Merkel
can be irritating you know with her
sermon preaching austerity probably the
same way her father was using the Bible
in his Germany trying to fight over
communism but indeed what she expresses
is common sense
it is true that all of us all of you
reasonable people we cannot spend that
much more than what we actually make it
just doesn't make sense
of course the eurozone is incomplete if
not a faulty system because it bonds
together creditor countries from the
north which have to support debtor
countries in the south I personally hope
that now that Merkel has been reelected
they will indeed be a minimum wage in
Germany and that will be quite a
revolution they will indeed be an
increase in domestic demand and that
will help the weaker state within the
European Union's
they need to be better mechanisms also
to strengthen the eurozone but we on the
continent we know that the euro is a
political project and
not only an economic and monetary one
that it's been folded from the start it
needs to be strengthened and within that
framework indeed
Germany will be again the engine of
Europe assuming of course there is more
cooperation and more solidarity between
us
so my last argument to convince you
ladies and gentlemen that indeed Merkel
is not destroying Europe what has
destroyed Europe are again irresponsible
and myopic governments which have now
been dismissed by their people to the
great ballooning of the extreme right in
these countries as just the fact that
Germany has no extreme right and so I
think the fact that there is now
recovery showing up timidly but still in
Spain and even in Greece is a good omen
for the times to come thank
Chrissa Doc Brown thank you very much
indeed first speak up against the motion
now euclid tsakalotos who is an
economics professor an MP for the
left-wing syriza party in greece
strongly opposes the government's
austerity measures co-authored a recent
book crucible of resistance greece the
eurozone and the world economic crisis
the floor is yours
Thank You Nick sixty years ago in this
very city in London Germany came here
after the war and got the following deal
firstly a haircut of her dead
secondly the Marshall Plan a huge
investment plan and thirdly a condition
that she would only pay back the bit of
the debt that wasn't cut if she had good
economic performance in terms of exports
and in growth so what was decided in
London 60 years ago that there would be
no return to the interwar period that
there would be no return to the
recession Germany would not be punished
for the Second World War we would not
have a debt trap again and we laid the
foundations for the Golden Age of
capitalism of the welfare state of
Social Security I will be very
interested to hear from historian of the
Second World War
why Germany was rightly not punished in
1953 but Greece should have been
punished in 2010 let me go back to the
beginnings how did we get into this
crisis we got into the crisis because
people believe neoliberal rhetoric they
believe that if you liberalized
everything there would be growth and
everybody was told borrow because we'll
have so much growth you'll be able to
pay it back so they said to people to
firms to households to banks to states
borrow and when that didn't happen when
we didn't have that growth and then when
we had a crisis what happened but we had
to discuss which contracts could we keep
after the crisis and what did Merkel
impose on Europe and imposed on Greece
that only one contract we would we keep
the contract to debtors to borrowers the
people who lent to us no other social
contract
not to our real people who we promised
that if you work hard the state will be
there to protect you not to are
pensioners where we promise that if you
worked hard the state would be there to
help you in your pension not to our
young people that we said if you educate
yourself if you go to universities
there'll be a job for there all those
social contracts have been broken
they've been broken because Greece Spain
and Portugal have created a state that
accept only one obligation to their
creditors is that a future for Europe
Greece is and now I'm appealing to your
hearts as well as to your minds because
all these social contracts are broken is
facing a humanitarian crisis I won't
milk this I won't tell you very many
examples but think of the lady who has
to give up her cancer treatment think of
a lighter example a small accumulation
the granny who can't this year give any
presence to the grandchildren think of
that what that does to a society how
people reacting to that in that society
we've been here before
we oppose Merkel and were struggling for
a new democratic Europe because we know
what happened when progressive
alternatives failed in the 1930s we know
that there are always generals on white
horses who are ready to come into the
vacuum left by politicians who have
abandoned every agenda on pensions on
wages on the welfare state I'm telling
you that opposing merkel is important
not just because of what she's doing but
what space she's creating for those
generals and white horses and we can
start here together and say and now I'm
speaking more as an economist as a
professor rather than a politician
there is no your social science that
says that neoliberal capitalism is the
only game in town
there is no economics law that says only
the private sector and the market can
respond to people's needs the inequality
within Western countries cannot last for
much longer the poverty in Western
economies cannot last much longer and if
we do not do something as we didn't do
with Spain in 1936 and the failure in
France in 1936 we know what the results
were the results were fascism and war
and we're close to that again bad things
happen not only when bad people do them
but when good people don't stand up and
stop them thank you very much
euclid tsakalotos thank you very much
indeed you've now heard the two main
speakers for the motion now the second
speaker against the motion
Antony beaver award winning historian
his latest book is the number one
international bestseller the second
world war
Antony beaver the froy's yours it is not
angular Merkel who is destroying Europe
it is the eurozone instead of
accelerating the unification of the
continent has hoped the experience has
divided it and divided it with
bitterness let us remember the
background to the euro it stemmed from
German unification France was afraid of
the power of a greatly enlarged Germany
and the deal was that German power would
be locked up within the European Union
and a common currency this led to the
Treaty of Maastricht and Germany with
grave misgivings at the time agreed to
give up the deutsche mark to accept the
euro it is totally wrong to blame Merkel
when the fault always lay with the euro
system itself
you simply cannot expect to have a
stable form of monetary union between
independent nations which have huge
differences in productivity in fact it
is the one-size-fits-all basis of the
euro system with no debtor country able
to devalue or raise or lower interest
rates which makes the problem impossible
to resolve to have attempted monetary
union before political union was madness
but the true believers were far too
carried away by their dream or in the
case of France with the idea of the Euro
rivaling the United States dollar and of
a united Europe challenging American
power European bankers even failed to
see the dangers when Club Med countries
began a borrowing and spending spree
something which they would never have
been able to do with the lira
peseta or drachma Germany as it turned
out has certainly profited from the
imbalance in productivity but German
taxpayers
after many years of austerity and pay
restraint at home to deal with the
immense costs of unification in their
end
country never imagined that the European
Central Bank would have to rescue other
countries from their recklessness did
nobody in Athens Rome Madrid and Lisbon
ever sit down to work out how they were
going to pay it back or did they just
think that those who lent them the money
would simply go away and forget about it
like most Germans Angela Merkel believes
in thrift saving and hard work she is no
autocrat she knows that she has to
correct carry her country with her the
European Union is still very far from
becoming a reality and Germany remains a
sovereign state
so Merkel although enjoying great
popularity at home still has to be seen
to wear the armor of national interest
this is at a time when the majority of
Germans are becoming increasingly
reluctant to subsidize countries which
got themselves into trouble through
insane levels of spending meanwhile the
Germans who as I said had been reluctant
anyway at the time to abandon the
deutsche mark were promised that no
member country would be responsible for
the debt of others that supposedly meant
no bailouts the question is how long can
Europe continued to provide bailouts
without the reforms essential to
restoring economic competitiveness even
France the second largest economy in the
eurozone might be having to join the
club made countries as it's
uncompetitive economy declines
disastrously the euro crisis has often
been described as the longest train
crash in history and there is little
chance of it being solved in its present
form Angler Merkel is also deeply
troubled by Europe's increasing
inability to pay for its expensive ways
she recently emphasized I quote Europe
accounts for just over seven percent of
the world's population 25 percent of its
economy and 50 percent of total world
welfare spending in other words Europe
is out spending the rest of the world by
roughly 7 to 1 in welfare per head of
population if Europe cannot compete with
outside world it will soon not be able
to pay for any social services at all as
I say
is not Angela Merkel you should blame it
is the euro system itself which is
tearing Europe apart if Spain had stuck
with the peseta Italy with the lira and
Greece with the drachma none of this
would have happened
addley beaver thank you very much indeed
we've now heard too for the motion to
against the motion in a moment it's for
you to contribute to this debate where
the for or against or sitting on the
fence how are you thinking when you came
into this hall a short time ago well let
me share with you the ballot as you came
in
29% haven't made up their mind 18%
believe she is destroying Europe 53% of
you don't believe she is so on your side
you have a lot of work to do to persuade
the 29% to move one way or the other or
it could be that you've got to do a bit
of persuading as well to keep those on
your side right we have six microphones
going right to the back first my name is
Robert vulvas I'm a Dutchman I voted
against the motion my question to the
panel is why should hard-working
Northern Europeans pay for say the
Greeks who have for years not able not
being able to collect the taxes from the
Rome elites many of whom live in London
houses we'll come to that in a moment
right down here at the front the young
man has the microphone
hi there I've voted for the motion at
the beginning if we've got such a large
debt to pay off and a deficit to to
balance a budget to balance why are we
looking to get that money from the poor
because by definition the poor don't
have that much money so we will it's not
effective way of paying off the debt
surely you should be getting the money
from people you have most thank you
right who has the microphone please
stand up hi my name is James Ward and
I'm strongly for the motion you talk
about Germany's ability to restore its
competitor competitiveness from being
the sick man of Europe it did this an
environment where there was quite high
inflation around Europe so it was able
to restore its competitiveness without
deflation Germany is rigidly against
inflate
which means that the southern economy is
to regain competitive themselves they
have to have deflation that's just a
mathematical reality that is extremely
bad and I think that's one of the
biggest problems with Merkel's sticking
in the euro and expecting austerity
right first of all you cleared that
question about why should Europeans keep
bailing out the Greeks well there's a
flip answer to that
why should Greek bailout northern banks
because that's what they did and that's
what the program did the program was
structured so that northern banks in
France and Germany could offload their
debt and not create the crisis but
there's a more serious and less flip
answer to the question the West has a
common problem and that common problem
is in the last 20 years of neoliberalism
they haven't been able to spread the
goodies they haven't been able to
encompass some elements of the middle
class and the lower classes and what do
they do an American Britain they lend to
them the junk world
bones were loans to the poorest
Americans and that created a crisis
through private David Irish news let me
finish and in Greece they did it through
public debt neoliberalism failed then
the level of medium income the standards
of living have thoroughly improved in
Europe including in Greece and again I
fully agree with the Dutch gentleman if
your elites
hadn't had been a little bit more
responsible hadn't fled with capital
abroad I don't go for that you see
there's something
well cool about the Mediterranean very
tiresome in Greece it's the conspiracy
theory it's always a conspiracy it's
always oh it's these Nordic banks all
banks make a profit including some Greek
banks not all the phrase from Kristine
Okrand earlier was incompetent myopic if
not corrupt elites
the banking system we have now isn't
even capital no that particular point
I'm using when they make my Opik if not
I'm speaking about the elites of the
banking sector who when they were making
money ted their mummy Gilly and now that
they're not making money want us to
socialize them
that is the myopic that is the elite
that is a responsible and we should
treat them can I respond to the
gentleman at the back that the guy who
made the question I mean two points very
very quickly number one this whole
dynamic and I mentioned in my speech
about hard-working northerners lazy
feckless this whole divisive rhetoric is
part of the reason why Merkel is
destroying Europe because the European
project is breaking down around these
kind of crude stereotypes and weird
empirically free ill feelings towards
one another knows it's failed States but
Merkel's response to the currency unit
crisis it was exacerbated this problem
it's what's taking Greece from what
three years ago how many how many
quarters of contraction 20 22
consecutive quarters of contractors
thanks to austerity imposed by Germany
right no but what about the origins of
the problem I mean there is also insane
government spending you only want to see
what was being done in Greece during the
course of the elimination and in Spain
did a good thing we have a historian of
conflict up here right there's that one
particular question from the young
gentleman down here for you Anthony I
would actually agree with you clear on
one particular point we are facing a
fundamental crisis if you like in the
whole system of capitalism from the
point of view that in the past
capitalism was always making people even
at the bottom of the pile if you like
richer or slightly better off than they
were before that is no longer the no
longer the case and the reason for that
is got nothing to do with banks so it
has only in the sense that it is an
inevitable process of globalization once
you have the possibility of sourcing
labor all around the world you will then
get this appalling polarization of rich
and poor in that particular way and I
don't think there's any way of putting
the genie back in the bottle right let's
now move on I'd want to see those
against I'm coming to you in a moment
there are some ladies down here one you
have the microphone I hope and a second
behind you please okay simcha Heinkel
I'm a german journalist living in
britain for 15 years now and i'm
against emotion I'm still against
emotion but actually do you see me in
the peculiar situation today very much a
grievous god professor took a lot on set
and party before Antony beaver satyr so
all of you are most you're arguing from
a position that was true during in 2012
but it's not true anymore because German
politics has changed and has remarkably
changed and reasons the Euro has not
collapsed as actually that Merkel's now
contouring the austerity policy that is
stunned by the German Bundesbank which
is it all right pulpit three CCB's the
ECB's is actually spending and it's
doing the opposite from austerity thank
you and I'd like to encourage more
Germans more Spaniards more Greeks more
Portuguese anyone from any country
audience right who else has got the
microphone please we're going up to the
only now yes please I'm Greek I'm
reluctantly against the motion to
Professor tackle a dose may I ask you to
what extent have those politicians and
those people in positions of governance
taken a hit and mr. Hasan when you
mentioned dignity being lost in Greece
how does that compare to the dignity
that is often lost in a third world
country thank you the lady in the middle
has got the microphone hello my name is
Rafaela Evans I'm French Canadian and
American and I am against the motion
before and still and my point is it
seems these Club Med countries are
mostly macho countries does that point
out to the fact that maybe we need more
women on the board in the boardrooms and
in governments
thank you thank you I want to try and
keep it short I'm German I've lived here
for for more than 40 years I consider
myself a European I'm against the motion
i mr. Hasan mentioned Hitler in his
speech I object to that particularly in
connection with mrs. matter okay and I
you mentioned several times how many
hours the Greeks work it is not the
hours you work that counts what what you
produce in those hours I specifically
said that I'm not comparing Angela
Merkel to Hitler and I made a reference
to the point about the history and the
far-right parties so you're misquoting
me there on that Christine Okrent no I
agree that our son did not make the
Hitler comparison thank God right who
has got the microphone good evening my
name is Martin viola also German living
in the UK I originally voted against a
motion given the fact that both mr.
Hassan and mr. beaver pointed out that
maybe the euro is the problem I'm kind
of becoming undecided so the question is
can ask the panel should the euro be
polished or shook the eurozone move
towards a political union thank you ah
right let's move up to the balcony on my
left the floor is yours
please I think part of the problem with
a motion in favour is that they really
haven't said where the money should come
from there is a sense that managers
grows on trees and automatically it will
be produced a problem with a European
debt crisis is that there is no money in
the system to really bail these
countries out okay thank you a second
sorry the second point if I may
regarding banks banks have taken an
important haircut in terms of absorbing
part of the debt and in the cases where
this has not been applied the situation
has been much more disastrous we
the case of Cyprus it's always forgotten
that in Cyprus the banks were forced to
basically accept all the debts and the
whole system went bust and the criticism
was done on the other side on the
balcony on the right-hand side as I'm
looking up please thank you
Chris Paul Londoner against still
against with those for the motion
explain how they would develop an
economy where people borrow and don't
have to pay back the debt thank you
right let me put that very important
point from up on the balcony where
should the money come from you who are
speaking for the motion well there are
three ways of reducing debt Deptford and
no the three ways there's one way having
a haircut
the other way is to flate it and the
other way is not to ever pay back
America never paid its debt its second
world war dead because it just grew out
of it all the arguments were hearing
from people who are in against the
motion we've been through this before if
you make a country fall on its knees its
income goes down and you never get money
back that's the bottom line that's what
happened in 1930s all these arguments
were used in the 1930s of people have to
cut that we have to reduce wages we have
to quickly reduce government expenditure
and it doesn't work it didn't work in
the 1930s and it's not working now I
think they there is a key question which
was asked by the audience about the
eurozone should the euro be skipped and
it's a paradox of course by that my
co-panelists is of an opposite opinion
than mine the eurozone is a political
project which has had its good sides and
very bad sides I agree
Anthony beaver is right that it was
conceived as a as a political scheme but
without the institutional framework to
make it work the crisis
since 2008 has been so acute and the
measures of our government so timid that
now I think the time has come for the
eurozone to be strengthened but as far
as the euro is concerned just imagine
what it would be if each of our
countries would have to go back to the
national currency it would be a total
collapse of our economics the Dutch mark
would go up to such a degree that it
would in fact curtail the German economy
and it would do no good at all and other
currencies would collapse now I want to
get back to a nucleus remark earlier and
the impact he posed the question about
Germany being forgiving its debts after
in the early 50s and all the rest of it
and that of course was purely a
political decision during the Cold War
of restoring Germany that's certainly
true and were huge political
geopolitical aspects behind it so I
didn't even necessarily compare it with
the whole question yes a German economic
miracle it didn't have morality tales
about Americans are much more productive
and why should we support you they did
it and it works why won't it work this
time you have hold to that and why did
it work so that meant much better with
Germany rather than with France and the
reason was that the Germans were working
incredibly hard you know see the reports
of the American occupation forces on the
differences between what was happening
in France and what was happening in
Germany at the time but anyway leaving
that one aside that was certainly the
Marshall Plan nothing to do with
investments nothing to do is just
hard-working Germans by themselves they
think they could they could have said we
don't want the Marshall Plan we'll do it
by ourself because we'll work hard we
don't want the cuts in the debt at all
of course the Marshalls so well such
that made a huge difference and that is
where a goose and not a goose and a
gander thing is is well don't the
problem again comes back to where as we
were saying where where's the money
going to come from where as where the
interest rates going to go to as a
result afterwards we just like just a
point about the lady here mentioned Matt
show culture which is a very good point
I mean my objection to angular Merkel's
policies is it is a very macho take the
pain take the pain get on your knees
which is which is actually
usually destructive to human dignity
come back to the balcony and I just say
I just think and I think your take on
the pain this point about dead you know
we're hearing a lot about debt and
morality and you know who do you know
everyone's but let's not forget the
facts here
Merkel's policies are increasing the
debt maybe you haven't looked at the
statistics over the last three years
Italy's debt trajectory Greece's debt
rating Spain de is on the up not the
down that's why I'm saying austerity is
not working this idea you know Merkel
and the troika said in 2010 that if
Greece does what we tell it to do it
will contract for I think two and a half
percent of GDP and then it will recover
three years later its contracted by ten
times that amount how people can come
here and defend the person whose
predictions whose policies have failed
so miserably is people why is feign
economy picking up Oh everyone ants but
this is all the British come in fifty
percent unemployment has gone through
huge efforts tremendous suffering as
well from the people and it seems that
is is picking up and it's good news why
should we say no to good news actually
the EU forecast for the eurozone is not
good news at all for the next year right
if you look at European complain I want
to move this forward
go ahead my name is Jonah wise and I'm
for the motion I have a question for mr.
beaver your initial proposition was that
the euro was created upon uncertainty on
the part of France that they would
potentially face another attack by
Germany this is not the case it was in
fact a result of the Marshall Plan and
America's will for a European Federation
a program a program of fiscal stimulus
it is in fact basic macroeconomics that
spending supply side and demand side
spending will result in growth and a
reduction in debt as a country reaches
the height of the already economic cycle
Antony beaver well its first time I've
heard that the euro was dreamed up at
the Marshall Plan conference I mean my
father's part of the brief delegation
and I'm
don't remember him ever mentioning that
but I mean the euro I think as most
commentators at the time recognized was
very much that point when meteor was
deeply concerned about the unification
of Germany even worse he said I love
Germany so much I'd rather have to
exactly well also this is story about
Margaret Thatcher about how he tried to
persuade her Saint Margaret you know
Gorbachev you're the only person who can
stop unification of Germany and she was
very confused about this and actually
for once asked the Foreign Office what
they thought we were talking about angle
Merkel tonight not sorry all right okay
again but it right at the back go ahead
please which way are you thinking and my
name's Luna Walker and I'm undecided
probably leaning towards the fort but
I've got a question for against and is
Angela Merkel destroying Europe it's in
the present tense
could the against motion please give one
action they think Angela Merkel should
take now in the next couple of months
that would improve Europe not destroy it
as I mentioned American will get into a
coalition government that will change
the dynamics of German policies so I
personally believe that the grand
coalition which is supported by a
majority of Germans will bring a better
balance because the SPD insisting on the
minimum wage will also inject more
demand for internal consumption and that
should in a way balance better the
continental economies also some
economies predict that German Germany
has had it very good for now but that
actually the forecast is not that good
so Christine essentially Merkel's best
thing to do is to listen to critics of
austerities what you're saying no Merkel
oh it's like this experience for the
third time she's a perfectly legitimate
Democratic leader obviously supported by
her
citizens she's also but the policies
things you know very well respected
left-wing in your a raised Imam and
she's started I'm very well respected in
France she's perceived as a serious
politician which in other European
countries some people envy let's have
more voices please a lady in the middle
please yes you have the microphone hello
my name is Andrew Jones and I'm for the
motion but I ask the opposition we heard
quite a few points of humanitarian like
this is a humanitarian crisis and but it
was it is undoubtable fact in the
marshall plan put germany ahead when i
think we should do the same favor to
greece in the fact that it shouldn't be
scorned by the banks and obviously
overspending by the elite few when it's
actually people that are now going to
suffer and I think Germany should have
some humanitarian sibility just like we
showed it went with the Marshall Plan I
feel that would be fairer Christine do
you want to respond to that there is
indeed a great deal of humanitarian
concern about Greece and other countries
in Europe suffering from the crisis but
we're not discussing humanitarian
rosacea nobody discussion sorry
discussing and Wiggles if anything II
sure you're saying Europeans are a lot
of Europeans have shown a lot of
solidarity to Greece and to Spain and to
Portugal and everybody's grateful and
they and we think that that is part of
the answer the question is is the
imposition of austerity leading to the
kind of politics and results that we saw
in the 1930 and a neither of you have
said anything about our young that young
lady in the back what she said about the
marshal right that's here research prove
that right at the back and then the
gentleman at the front yes but my name
is Nick I live in London I was born in
Australia there is one way that this
could be solved and Germany could be
paid back the euros that they're owed
and that is if Germany were to leave the
euro that way the southern countries
would devalue the euro they would
prosper with the devalued currency and
they would pay back Germany
what Germany was owed albey
it wouldn't be quite worth what-what
Germany might be hoping for and I'd like
to ask that question to Antony beaver
given his superb knowledge of history
and that is certainly absolutely that is
certainly one solution I mean the idea I
didn't even II would like to do it on
its own I think the question of how
Germany will deal with it in the future
can could be solved in that particular
way but the Germany would not like to
leave the euro on its own I think you
much more prefer to her say have a
northern euro with Netherlands perhaps
Finland and so forth and basically no
just it's financial markets which decide
of the value of the euro yes it's not
any government so the idea that a
government would suddenly decide let's
devalue the euro doesn't make sense
right
it has been a fascinating debate and
you've been voting let me remind you how
you voted before the debate 29% of you
did not know whether you had a view on
Angela Merkel is destroying Europe 53%
of you were against that when we started
this debate 18% were for the motion the
result is that at least 19% of you have
come to a view there are only 10% of you
who is still undecided but the vote is
for the motion 23% against the motion
67% that's up from 53% so this side of
the house has one
so the motion that Angela Merkel is
destroying Europe has been defeated by
Christine Oakland and Anthony beaver and
I have to tell you that your support for
the motion has not succeeded so thank
you very much indeed for a very vibrant
debate on this critical issue our thanks
to the speakers to you here in the
Cadogan hall in London and my thanks as
well to intelligence squared for making
this possible
so for me Nik gowing thank you to all of
you for joining us bye-bye